if you want to be able to do really cool
stuff then your training is not
necessarily going to look really cool if
you want to be able to jump really high
run really fast and do cool flips and
stunts then a lot of the time the
training you're doing is actually going
to look pretty basic and boring and
there's no better example of this than
the reverse plank which is about as
static and dull as it comes but it can
unlock some incredible athletic benefits
not only that but the reverse plank is
also a fantastic exercise for everyone
else it's low barrier to entry makes it
the perfect choice if you just want to
improve your strength and mobility if
you want to prevent injury in your spine
and if you want to restore a normal
level of function so this is a really
overlooked and underrated exercise i
think more people should know about and
that's what we're going to be discussing
today to start with i better show you
what the reverse plank looks like you
know what a plank looks like you just
rest your body on your hands or your
forearms with your
stomach facing the ground and then just
try and hold that for as long as you can
the reverse plank is the opposite thing
you're gonna lie there with your belly
button pointing up to the sky
i think adults call them navels resting
on your hands and trying to keep your
torso as straight and rigid as you can
for as long as you can so it looks like
this
hands turned out or to the side it
doesn't matter too much
and then you just hold
aim for a minute if you can 30 seconds
is fine
and simple that might look that is going
to work wonders so when you do the
regular plank the idea is obviously to
strengthen the rectus abdominal the
sheet of muscle that makes up your
six-pack on the front of your stomach
and this is really useful for someone
who perhaps lacks core strength to a big
degree who can't do a push-up for
example
but as you get stronger and as you get
more experienced it's not really as
important and the big reason for this is
that things like the push-up already
strengthen your rectus abdomini and
improve your anti-extension strength as
in your ability to prevent your body
flexing backwards
or extending backwards which is what the
plank is all about this can help prevent
back issues but
actually we spend most of our time
already in a hunched forwards position
if you're working at a desk for instance
you're going to be in hunch four's
position so it's not so much
anti-extension you need it's actually
anti-flexion that becomes more important
which is something that you can train
with things like goblet squats anything
that prevents your body from bending
forwards
but when you perform reverse plank the
opposite thing wants to happen you're
like this and your body wants to fall
this way your waist wants to collapse
bringing your buttocks closer towards
the ground so now you need to engage the
erector spinae and the glutes to prevent
that from happening and to straighten
yourself back out and this is so useful
because when you think about it how do
you normally put your back out it's when
you bend over to pick something up and
then you don't have the strength or
you're tired out in your back and the
erector spinae is what goes so that's
really what you want to strengthen if
you struggle with back pain or all kinds
of other things and one of the ways that
a lot of people strengthen these muscles
is by using superman's so they lie on
their fronts and then they raise their
arms and their legs up behind them to
create a kind of concave shape and i
think this is actually fine but some
people such as dr stewart mcgill the
back mechanic
think that it isn't so good and the
reason for that is that it creates a lot
of spinal compression which can actually
potentially cause degradation and maybe
injury especially if you're someone
who's prone to back pain already so
mcgill recommends movements where you're
not actually bending the spine but
instead you're maintaining a still
position so as to increase spinal
stiffness and prevent injury that way
and to provide the stability that can
alleviate some of the pain now i
personally believe that a bit of spinal
mobility is important and there's no
harm in flexing and extending the spine
i'm not alone in thinking that either if
you look at some really impressive
gymnasts they have tons of mobility in
their spine they use exercises that bend
their backs all over the place and they
still have that strength
however if you're prone to injury or if
you want to air on the side of caution
this is the perfect antidate because it
allows you to build that strength
without adding any compression it's
super safe and highly effective if that
was all the reverse plank did it would
be a fantastic movement however it also
does a whole lot more for one if you
focus on keeping your arms straight and
locked out at the elbows this is also
another good way to practice straight
arm strength you're getting your bang
for buck there by doing more than one
thing at once straight arm strength is
your ability to exert strength with your
arms locked out this is really useful
for movements like the crow pose like
handstands like planche training like
l-sit and v-sit in other words it'll
unlock all other kinds of cool skills
it's also great for strengthening your
biceps preventing tears during exercises
like the deadlift and another great
thing this does for you is it
strengthens your glutes and your
hamstrings because effectively to
maintain that isometric cold you need to
almost be trying to curl the ground to
push yourself back up as though you're
doing a hamstring curl and this of
course has lots of transfer lots of
carry over to athletic performance
particularly running we need to be able
to do the same thing off the ground to
push yourself forwards quickly so
surprisingly this very simple looking
exercise can improve your athletic
performance as well as just preventing
back pain and improving general health
is it just me or do things look like
super high definition today or something
and of course you're also getting some
shoulder mobility in there because you
might find this position is quite
difficult to get into if you lack a lot
of shoulder mobility so you're getting
all these things for the price of one
you get your core stability resistance
against back injury you get shoulder
mobility you get gluten hamstring
strength and potentially improved
athletic strength and straight arm
strength all by just practicing this one
position and then making it more
difficult or more easy depending on your
level and it's something you can do
whilst you're watching the tv as for
those easier variations of course you
can put your hands up onto something a
bit higher so effectively you're just
doing a kind of dip but where you're not
moving yourself down or of course you
can just bend your legs which also makes
life a little bit easier by reducing the
lever arm but of course then you're
going to get
some lesser benefits obvious harder
variations are a to lift one leg at a
time thereby increasing the amount of
resistance on the glutes and on the
hamstrings um make sure you do both
sides evenly of course or you can just
put weight on your waist and this will
obviously mean that you have to now
resist that to keep your body nice and
straight
but things get even more interesting
once you start introducing some slight
alternatives not just variations so an
example is the glute bridge which i'll
do a video on in future but basically
you're going to lie that on your back
with your feet now flat on the floor
knees bent and then curl your buttocks
off the ground and the way to do this is
by adding a weight a barbell or a weight
plate to your midriff and then raising
that as you go and this is a fantastic
exercise that has a lot of benefits for
athletes an alternative is to use the
tabletop position which is the same
thing but with your legs bent and you
want to try and maintain as flat a torso
as possible and you can then turn this
into the crab walk from movement
training so now you're just moving
forwards from that position which opens
up the shoulders really nicely
strengthens the core all whilst you're
moving around so you don't feel bored
just sitting there on the spot
this then leads really nicely into the
crab reach where you reach yourself
backwards which gives you that nice
rotation in the thoracic spine another
missing area of mobility for a lot of
people that can then lead to all kinds
of other movements
it's just great that you're progressing
in all these different areas all at once
and if you want to you can then flow
these things together in order to create
a really interesting combination that's
not boring and it provides even even
more benefits
so there you go guys that's the reverse
plank do you like it let me know if you
already use it or if you're going to
start using it now and if you'd like to
see more videos like this i was being
coy but of course this is a new camera
setup and i have you guys at patreon to
thank for this so thank you so much for
making this possible i hope you like the
new quality i'm just taking out for a
spin today with a relatively low
intensity video something relatively
easy to put together but hopefully it's
going to really increase the production
values here on the channel so thanks so
much and i really hope you guys
appreciate the new resolution
[Music]
and next week at some point i'm going to
be uploading the home batcaves video
thank you so much to all of you who
submitted so if i took a while to
respond to you if i haven't yet yeah it
should be really cool video and there's
still time if you want to get your
submission in head over to the facebook
page
facebook.com you'll see the post there
and you just need to respond to that
with a picture or a video or you can dm
me etc and i'll try and get it into that
video if there's still time if you like
this kind of functional training that
improves your athletic performance and
your mobility and your health then you
might enjoy my ebook and training
program super functional training
there's a discount on right now whilst
the pandemic is ongoing for many of us
and i'll put a link to that in
description down below either way thank
you so much for watching this one guys
stay tuned for more like it and i'll see
you next time
bye for now
[Music]
you